his policies do not benefit most
Americans rich or poor Bernie Sanders is
war is with you I want to know what your
main problem is with Bernie Sanders like
I talked about I think with Bernie this
is going to be really really dirty going
to the primary this is best-case
scenario for president Donald Trump and
I don't think that people are right when
they assume that if Bernie drops out his
Bernie bros the brown shirts are gonna
be voting for Joe Biden no I don't think
they're gonna be voting for Joe Biden
and I think a higher percentage of them
will vote for Trump
then for Biden that people are
accounting for yeah we saw a lot of that
in 2016 we saw the Bernie bros come into
this channel often well you know what at
least he's going to burn it all down
he's anti-establishment they've been
portrayal certainly on issues of trade
on issues of war they would line up with
Trump more than Bernie but my big issue
with bernie is that he paints all of his
political opposition or he acts as
though it's a monolith were the only
people who could ever even fathom
opposing his policies must be special
interest billionaires and for context
this is what I'm talking about our
campaign is about taking on the powerful
special interest that dominate our
economic and political life today we
have a corrupt campaign finance system
[Applause]
with Wall Street and billionaires
spending unlimited sums of money which
is undermining American democracy we
need to take on the corporate elite we
need a government that works for working
families not just big campaign is to
make it clear that we're not gonna give
tax breaks to billionaires and large
corporations they're gonna start paying
their fair share of taxes little things
blow in a field and the little white
purchases Wall Street and align the
insurance and the drug companies the
fossil fuel industry the
military-industrial complex
okay lots of buzz word think we would
all agree if what do you if what he was
saying or at least I guess sort of the
premise there if it was if you were true
sure Bernie would be the champion of the
people
waging war against the corrupt rich
elite got it if you buy that premise but
what if it's not true what if there are
plenty of people out there who oppose
Bernie's policies and ideas and they're
not billionaires what if it's just a
significant portion potentially a
plurality or in some cases a serious
majority of Americans who are opposed to
these policies proposed from Bernie
Sanders well then that changes things
because Bernie's war is not with rich
elitist billionaires Bernie's war is
it's with you so let's first start with
energy fossil fuels right yeah
the first example is that this is of him
trying to frame the argument in
demonizing 100 percent of his political
opposition as it relates to fossil fuels
and energy I'm talking about Wall Street
the health insurance companies the drug
companies the fossil fuel industry the
military-industrial complex the private
prison industry and the large
multinational corporations that exert
such an enormous influence over our
lives okay did he see a lot of the same
puzzle yeah I love how he just always
conveniently says the list of people who
should consider him
their enemy right he's just very clearly
like I hate conservatives and
Republicans and Democrats and moderates
and people with legs don't work and
people who live in America like all of
you suck yeah buddy vote for me and
people who don't have to stick the
morphine drip in their head he's just
very clearly the opposition candidate to
everyone right and they see Franzen is
that was his wars with big fossil fuel
industry and that's what these people
are very easy Adem Adem in eyes and I'm
not going to defend all pharmaceutical
companies I'm not going to be defending
all fossil fuel industries okay I'm not
defending the BP oil spill but in
reality here when he's painting it with
this broad stroke his war is against you
middle-class Americans who
overwhelmingly like to drive your own
cars as opposed to public transit and
often choose SUVs and poll after poll
after poll has shown that affordable gas
is a very important issue to most
Americans by the way absolutely it's
even more important to non wealthy
Americans Bernie doesn't think about how
much it costs to gas up is Prius so
every day cost it's an everyday cost for
everyday people right that they see the
tangible changes with Donald Trump when
he comes out and he makes the economy
better and it drives the prices down and
by the way when I say Bernie's Prius I
mean an old shopping cart with a
lawnmower engine yeah one thing I always
find interesting about burning when he
talks about a specific industry is he's
forgetting that sure there are people
who are making millions or billions of
dollars and the companies may be making
billions of dollars but they're also
spending billions of dollars YES on
innovation on fuel efficiency on hiring
engineers all the way down to the people
who were cleaning the offices they're a
role in the thing he never thinks about
is I'm gonna destroy this industry okay
every voter that works in those
companies every voter that works in a
company that's affiliated with one of
those companies know he's coming for you
not just the CEO not just the CFO he's
coming for you when they can't afford to
do their work anymore because there's a
higher price you will pay the price
let's move on to something that affects
a lot of Americans one of the biggest
issues health care drug comprises right
this is kind of all lumped in together
Burnie I don't think we have a clip for
this one but you can just take my word
for it that Bernie Sanders hates
insurance company company I'm lying
there gonna be someone like world wars
reference ever everything he's ever said
everywhere find a video Bernie Sanders
speaking hit play wait 30 seconds try
and look through the IV hooked up to his
head for summary what was vascular leak
challenge I had Super Mario characters
on ya Luigi the Children's Ward gosh so
he frames this right when we're talking
about insurance companies and we're
talking about pharmaceutical companies a
lot of lot of regulation a lot of
corruption with some of these companies
absolutely what he frames it as though
the only reason that we have private
insurance in the United States is
because of the wealthy elites pulling
the strings right the presumption is
that the only reason one could oppose
his mandatory Medicare for all program
is if they're wealthy elite but in
reality his wars with you Americans
we're over 83% of you are currently
satisfied with your health insurance
plan and by the way his wars with eighty
seven percent of Americans out there you
who are against a universal health care
plan if it eliminates private insurance
which is exactly what Bernie Sanders
plan would do don't allow TYT don't
allow Seth Meyers don't allow Trevor
Noah or the TYT Network funded by a you
know foreign caliphate to tell you well
Medicare for all socialized health care
is immensely popular right this is not
fringe is's mainstream eighty seven
percent of americans let's say it we're
lower down let's say it was only eighty
percent okay you can't find a number
that says eighty they're all they're all
eighty seven something eighty eight
eighty seven percent of americans when
you say okay but what if Medicare for
all required that we completely
eliminate private insurance they say no
no way no how
so if you ask people abstractly do you
like you currently up no no no I like my
current health care plan don't buy it
wouldn't make it right by the way to
eliminate private insurance it's still
morally reprehensible but for mister
Paul himself
it's not even popular and something else
to take into account Bernie's war
obviously is with you the middle-class
Americans but it's also he also has a
war with innovation and he has award for
a man who fancies himself a man of the
world listen take this
count the United States leads the world
in drug development and I think you know
you buy more we've talked about this
it's not even close now the reason our
drugs cost more is that other countries
freeload off of our drug development and
then impose price controls in their
countries that drive American drug costs
up it's often socialist price controls
in other countries that drive up
American drug prices not only the drug
companies if you were gonna go buy
medicine or drugs or a treatment or a
remedy from somewhere are you gonna buy
it from Venezuela or Cuba or Russia or
Iran or Iraq any of those places
Afghanistan or you can apply it from
somewhere that has a strong capitalist
society that allows for innovation and
the conglomeration of wealth in one
place so that you can spend ten years
right and multi-billion dollars on a
single drug that may not even make it
even further than that because you do
have some Americans who buy drugs in
Mexico who buy drugs so we're made in
the USA exactly yeah they're subsidized
by these other governments because they
don't spend the RMD cost no they don't
innovate and so what happens is then
it's footed by the taxpayer at a fifty
to fifty six seventy percent tax rate
depending on where you're going right
that's something else that's important
if you get in another country cheaper
that's because we're footing the bill
just like Canada hey defend your own
borders go
that'd be entertaining for about I don't
know power and then you'd be waving the
American flag and using our currency so
fast it would make your silly little
Mountie head spin by the way I hit the
notification bell and hit all
notifications turn them on on your phone
please
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot anymore and we're not really all
that searchable he type in the name of
this show tomorrow it won't show up
Young Turks well and please do consider
joining Mudd Club because this show that
you enjoy we do them every day Monday
through Thursday but on the paywall and
you also get everyone else you get
roaming millennial you get climb back
you get Mark Levin you get who else am I
thinking about here other people oh you
get dave rubin anyway you do the show
with Miguel
now I've got a mouth to feed coming okay
this is so fun oh oh I also should have
mentioned next week we are going to do
our 1 billion view live nice I should be
clear it's it's more ceremonial we cross
1 billion views a while ago but and we
had to remove the videos because of the
fig shirt you know yeah we're gonna re
cross it will also be doing a live
stream when we cross the Young Turks and
subscribership which would be happy to
order nice so yeah I just saw sear
election time the Young Turks down but
technically they still have more
subscribers and uh so we can you know we
have a couple more months is an easy
target right speaking of no next big
target but huge causes what a sniffer so
this is and it's like Greta Van Susteren
we're seeing the new and improved Greta
we're seeing the new and improved Young
Turks I was watching them with Super
Tuesday going guys please do join up
whatever their Pakistan we apps and by
the way we wouldn't ask if we didn't
need it ok all these other multi-billion
dollar companies like what a second what
happened to the 20/30 million dollars
that you got an investment from
al-jazeera and Google and Buddy Roemer
we've never received any of that so how
do you need money now hmm we just need
you guys to join up at Mudd Club we're
not funded by any other mobile it's
because their employees haven't yet
unionized right they're like the Mike
Bloomberg of YouTube channels actively
throwing the money away uh very short
okay here's another one and this one is
one that this is one that I think this
issue at large but not just talking
about Bernie Democrats will lose Joe
Biden said that that beta work was going
to be his guns are wrap it up no one's
over outdone fader O'Rourke
that's a big probably lost Texas
exclusively because of guns then Biden
said uh that's good you know what I'm
gonna have him do my guns along with my
wife sister I don't what is good
I shouldn't drink that bucket of salt
water why am i stopping yeah the guy
that lost twice
exactly how many rakes can he step on I
mean really only he thinks that they're
pool cues
there's no idea let's get to Bernie
Sanders he always tries to paint the
voice of opposition to his ideas his
proposals his gun policies as though it
must come from some sinister or
exclusively sinister Overlord
organization the Congress must do what
the American people want not what the
NRA wants okay but if we're talking
about what the NRA wants versus what
Bernie wants which really isn't all that
clear because you know I'm the most
pro-gun state in the Union you didn't
really do a whole lot to change it still
most Americans would side with the NRA
because his war again is with you
America 43% of your households include
guns 43 percent of American households
own guns and gun ownership rates are
highest by the way for those in the
middle income class tax bracket I think
it's worth 40,000 we have an overly
forty thousand two hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah they're the most
sense now big reason I don't know this
is just a theory a big reason that they
tend to be the highest percentage of gun
owners is because they can't afford the
armored car and security detail that
Bernie Sanders has out there okay yeah
that makes sense them it was a mystery
now it's solved just call the cops
people say that right there's coal right
well a lot of Americans middle-class
Americans if you look at that they would
live in the suburbs or they would live
in rural areas where police response
time might be slower so mr. Walther
takes care of them maybe for some folks
who buy a lesser farmer a lesser firearm
mr. Smith and Wesson yeah yeah you don't
believe never never forget that the
origination of a lot of gun restrictions
were completely based on racism they
were saying we're gonna limit certain
people in certain areas that to be able
to have them in predominantly effective
minorities and yet you see a huge
movement of folks who are saying look if
we can get rid of these restrictions and
let people regardless of their skin
color own firearms then we're gonna be a
better place to get Bernie on Iran ik
Lee tries to say that he is the
candidate for people of color even
though he's insisting that we should
make sure to keep guns out of the hands
Ortiz well we can't have anymore Pookie
Williams running around what he's cuckoo
for cocoa puffs am one of those masks in
Halloween where you squeeze the pump and
just like the blood squirting yeah yeah
thing in his head I think that's what he
was going for it's a genre and
apparently he wiped his head with
balloons to his Bernie Sanders sake not
the NRA but he slips and he's mentioned
many times that his stances his gun
stances not popular with voters
he is routinely cited this as a reason
for losing an election 30 years ago I
likely lost a race for the one seat for
Congress in Vermont because 30 years ago
I opposed I supported a ban on assault
weapons it's true he also pooped his
pants so right there at the pause one
try too hard you that in tandem right
yeah they were the game-changing effect
but which one was the leading you know
who knows that most Americans want your
kind of gun policy or you lost in
Vermont of all places if I'm not
mistaken because every gun policy let's
move on to the next one this goes back
to your point the claim from Bernie
Sanders about tax cuts right he loves to
say that Donald Trump they did the same
in with george w bush the tax cuts are
only about benefiting and these are the
people pulling the strings with the
election maybe you've bought this the
billionaire class the billionaire class
provides hundreds of millions of dollars
in campaign contributions to republicans
and now is payback time what this
legislation is about Jake is giving 50%
of the tax benefits to the top 1% I love
that he's a billionaire contributions to
Republicans what happened to Bloomberg
style exactly that's the GDP of all of
South America combined just to be raped
on the stage by Elizabeth Warren that is
it that is an expensive look it is an
expensive sectional accosting on a
national platform his war Bernie Sanders
or is with you because the Trump tax
cuts they reduced the income tax bill
for those by the way those earning a
median income in the country by nearly
60% household income for median income
families again is up four thousand
dollars and thirty four times the size
of what we saw under eight years of
Obama and here's something else his war
is not with big but his war is with the
vast majority of businesses that are
American small businesses yeah right the
Trump tax cuts have helped them a lot
and his approval rating just hit an
all-time high among small business
owners again a huge portion depending on
which numbers you use a majority of
Americans employed by small to mid-sized
businesses they're not Bernie voters so
Bernie he's not waging war against
Amazon in facebook
he is waging war against you the
mom-and-pop shops down the street
yeah with bond vino and with louder with
crowd or these are small businesses and
he's picking an issue that most people
are doing well most people are happy
with how the economy is going and is
like Oh fifty percent of the tax benefit
goes to the people that pay the absolute
most taxes right in the country right
that's not a bad thing let us pray them
let us not forgive that he is openly
admitted he is going to increase taxes
over twenty nine thousand years right
yeah you are paying any of those taxes
you are going to pay more under Bernie
Bernie he tries to frame it and I think
a lot of people have bought this this is
what bothers me so much about Bernie
that his war is with billion
billionaires and multi corporate
multinational conglomerate corporations
I'm trying to fit in all the buzz bore
too difficult he does it well and I
don't have that I don't have the Bane
poison mask on my forehead
he always cloaks it is that but Bernie's
war I want you to look into the policies
I want you to look like bill said about
who will see a tax increase I want you
to look into the polls and the fact that
Medicare for all would be mandatory
there would be no more private insurance
I want you to look into what his energy
policies would do and what they have
historically done with gas prices for
the average middle-class Americans
Bernie's war I want to be as clear as
humanly possible here his war is not
with the wealthy elite his policies do
not benefit most Americans rich or poor
Bernie Sanders is war is with you
if you like this segment subscribe or
hit one of these videos playing in boxes
hit the notification bell in all
notifications because subscriptions
don't necessarily mean a whole lot I
worked hard enough for it can you see
this red welt this red welt on my head
from it was this is this came from this
it wasn't very smart
I should have panned to mind it it's a
little inside baseball with with Theatre
nomenclature it's also taking about Oh
this segment is taken from a full show
on that Thursday so you should go watch
the full show if you liked it you
probably liked the full show and if you
don't you should get you get the hell
out